c'est the place to be pour les
personnalités politiques depuis sa
première édition en 1964 le salon de
l'agriculture est une vitrine médiatique
et en 1968
le président charles de gaulle ne
dérogeait pas à la règle quelle réussite
tel est le jugement porté par le général
de gaulle sur le livre d'or du salon de
l'agriculture après sa visite détaillée
le but est tout trouvé à part être plus
proche du peuple et changer l'image d'un
politicien trop sérieux en 1977
valéry giscard d'estaing un brin mal à
l'aise avec cet événement se plier à
l'exercice
ce matin le président de la république à
renouer avec la tradition en visitant
pendant plus de deux heures le salon si
certains politiques utilisent le salon
comme un moyen de communication régulier
d'autres le boudent comme françois
mitterrand il ne s'y rendra qu'une seule
fois en 1981 année électorale oblige il
s'agissait donc pour françois mitterrand
de tâter le pouls du milieu agricole de
se livrer à quelques explications sur ce
programme en revanche c'est tout le
contraire d'un certain jacques chirac
visiteurs assidus du salon il n'a raté
qu'un seul au cours de sa carrière
politique
brett chirac pratiquants vais y habituer
le salon tâter le cul des vaches il
connaît même si m
il faut rétablir une certaine vérité
touche pas jacques chirac le parisien et
maire de paris pendant près de 20 ans se
veut proche du monde rural
un team ensemble au chaud alors en 2005
il ne tarissait pas d'éloges sur les
bovins du salon avec une phrase devenue
culte
les superlatifs ne manquent pas pour
s'attirer les faveurs des agriculteurs
tous les moyens sont bons même si
certains éleveurs restent méfiants
vachement plus longtemps l'année
dernière ils sont passés assez vite en
plus est à la crise de la vache folle
donc balises à un peu c'est pas trop
rester avec les paysans cette année faut
serrer des mains caméra journalistes
tout y est pour que le salon soit un
rendez vous médiatique en 2012 pour
dorloter un monde rural en crise
le candidat à la présidentielle françois
hollande n'hésitez pas à mettre la main
à la pâte assister à la traite matinal
des vaches et des alors faire une beauté
il n'y a pas de doute françois hollande
est en campagne en 2017
emmanuel macron en pleine campagne se
donnait l'image d'un candidat jeune les
adeptes des réseaux sociaux
bien loin des codes ruraux et peu
importe en 2018
il s'y coller comme tout le monde une
poule à l'elysée moi j'ai adopté le
cadeau est un peu encombrant mais c'est
le prix à payer pour te plaît le prix à
payer pour grappiller quelques voix et
nul doute que cette année encore la
classe politique prendra son temps le
salon d'art et culture
[Musique]